I I really appreciate you you taking the
time and I want to get into a little bit
of like the details of this film but
then also yourself to start out because
you recently made your directorial debut
and I was curious if that changed your
approach to this type of film or gave
you a different perspective knowing what
it's like to be on the other side of the
camera oh thank you for yeah that's such
a generous question to ask and
definitely it did change my point of
view
of what do on set and what directors are
worried about on set because I've always
I would say had that wrong what I
thought actors were doing on set was
less
valuable and what I thought directors
were doing on set was worrying about
their actors and I realized those two
things were wrong What actors do on set
is so valuable and I only learned that
from seeing the other side of it seeing
the two actors who were in my movie
Julian Moore and Finn wolfard poured
their heart out every day bring their
emotions to
something it's what I had been doing on
sets as an actor but never appreciated
until I saw somebody else do it and so
being on set of a movie like manad Drome
where the focus was so much on me and my
acting because the part is so extreme
and it's such a central kind of
character movie um I learned to kind of
give myself a break and think that oh
yes what I'm doing is you know let's say
maybe has some value in the Arts in some
big way so I don't have to feel like I'm
just doing something Vain and
self-centered and then I also this other
feeling which is like oh yes I could
feel totally comfortable just using
myself in every possible base way
because that's what's going to make this
good and I've kind of always understood
that intuitively but never felt totally
comfortable with it and the other thing
that I learned which I mentioned is like
just um seeing what directors are
worried about again I always assume
directors are walking around between
takes being angry at me that I did a bad
job because I'd be so
self-punishing during the take after the
takes I missed that moment or shoot I
wanted to do this thing I couldn't do it
or I wasn't engaged in the moment in
that particular take and I assume the
directors all knew that too and were
walking around Furious but they weren't
and I realized that too because again
Julian Moore is like the greatest you
know actress in the country would say to
me I missed that take whereas I thought
this is the greatest thing I've ever
seen in my life and so I realized act
directors aren't walking around just
being mad at me and so again in a movie
like manad Drome where the movie is so
focused on my
particular acting job um I let myself
off the hook of worrying that I was
doing a bad job that sounds like it was
very creatively freeing then to take on
something like this it's exactly that
exactly freeing knowing how the process
works as an outsider uh is always
freeing I think yes and also compassion
for actors which I always always always
have had was just increased the best
advice I ever got on a movie set was
this director Greg Mata who was
directing Adventure land that I was in
and I had like a little minor panic
attack during a take and I kind of just
froze and I asked the director can we
stop for a minute and I brought him to
the side and I said I think I just had a
panic attack and I ruined the scene and
he said well you didn't ruin the scene
and I saw you were a little
uncomfortable but I'd be surprised if
you didn't have a panic attack in every
take what you're doing is like this
emotionally explicit thing you're using
yourself your face is on camera it's
like I would freak out for one second as
an actor and that was the best advice I
ever got because it allowed me to kind
of take the burden off myself for
worrying that I was going to screw
something up that was going to screw the
movie up yeah when you when you talk
about kind of that intensity of the
experience it's hard to think of a movie
as intense as this in some key moments
both in the domestic scenes in the
scenes you share with Adrien
Brody have you
become
more prepared to dive into something
like that because of past experiences
you've had or is was this in a new Beast
entirely I've I I always prefer things
like this they just don't come around as
frequently as you know more kind of how
to describe it casual kind of roles yeah
because they're not made that much um
but my background is in theater as an
actor and um I write and act and plays
for myself and the characters are close
to this level of um drama and intensity
um but just no one sees them you know
because they're plays and uh but so this
is that would be the kind of role I
would create for myself something at
that with that ex extreme uh at that
extreme level and so I'm very
comfortable frankly more comfortable in
roles like this than in kind of casual
roles because when I'm in a kind of
casual role that appears like myself I'm
often just worried that I'm inauthentic
you know because you're so
self-conscious because it's so similar
to you whereas this you're like
basically in somebody's nightmare
scenario and in some ways like that's
more comfortable place to be in because
it's not like there are these very
strict rules that you have to adhere to
about how your character would behave
because no one knows how your character
would behave it sounds like there's a
distance that you appreciate in the
roles that you take on that's a perfect
way to put it uh because he's not like
me and doesn't react like me I could be
completely Artful with it you know I
find it pretty stifling when you're
playing a character that's so similar to
you to really dig into your creative
imagination because it's something you
wind up because it's similar to what
you're doing all day by yourself you
know and so with a movie like this and
I've been in a few movies where I got
this kind of let's say leeway or
creative freedom uh I just have this
thought every day on set like oh this is
the gift this is why I would do maybe a
commercial movie that didn't exactly
that I didn't exactly feel engaged with
it's for this reason it's so I get to do
this which is like being in the greatest
acting class in the world but
also it's in a movie that people will
see how lucky is that no absolutely it
sounds like there's that and it's the
cliche phrase of one for them one for me
but this sounds like this was the one
for you yes exactly and sometimes the
one for them is also one for you like
I've had unbelievably great experiences
in that world too but you know you know
sometimes you feel like wait what you
know what what is the end goal with a
particular thing and then when you're
acting in something that feels totally
real and authentic and like you're
stretching your creative brain you think
all right this is what I assumed I would
be doing all the time when I was in
drama school when you're in drama school
you do you know Greek plays and you play
Stanley Kowalski at 16 years old and
then you get out of acting school and
you're auditioning for a Trident gum
commercial where you're trying to like
show that you're smiling you know into
the camera but you know your teeth are
not going to be good enough to get the
part and so you just you this Assumption
of what acting is and the reality of
what acting is are normally like never
in accordance except for like times like
this I just had a nightmare Vision that
this movie would be the most terrifying
re-edit into a Trident gum commercial
possible yes yes exactly I wonder you
could probably actually keep a lot of it
but it would be one of these like you
know bastardized art housee versions of
yeah it would maybe it would be also
like a commentary on the dangers of
Gummer yeah yeah I wanted to ask
specifically about one scene and it was
the tape scene where you wrap the tape
around your face oh yeah I had thoughts
of like where I had remembered similar
things from but I was wondering how that
came to be and what the origin point of
that
was when I first read the script it's it
really read to me as somebody who had
transcribed a nightmare and so there
were all of those thing there were all
of these things in the script that were
like um I would say logically not
totally explainable to me but
emotionally felt real and so like a guy
who's struggling with his own identity
with his own masculinity with his own
face this is something we probably all
struggle with to a certain degree
because it's part of our ego and vanity
but this is somebody who's experiencing
it at like an unbelievably extreme
dangerous level and so like the thing
with the tape on the face was like oh
yeah of course this person would do that
this person who hates himself of course
would put tape all over his face not
only because he's trying to distort the
very thing that he resents which is his
own appearance but um it's also painful
and this is somebody who is self Haring
and so oh this is exactly emotionally
realistic to me but if I Tred to explain
you know to an outsider why he's doing
this particular thing you know you kind
of struggle up against it which is this
beautiful thing about you know when you
can read a script that feels emotionally
honest even if it's somehow occasionally
illogical no absolutely I think that
emotional honesty is is kind of the core
of this where it's very very painful but
there's there's a truth to it nothing
even as it has its surreal moments
there's that truth to it and I was
wondering were there truths you
discovered in the process of going
through this that you maybe didn't have
at the beginning yeah that is such a
good question and the answer is yes but
I've never been asked it before and I
can't think of an exactly no that's okay
scene but it it's exactly right it's
that this happens all the time by the
way with actors halfway through doing a
movie you go oh now I finally get it or
halfway through doing a play you know
you have six months left on a run that's
a year long you're like oh now I finally
get it I wish I could do those six
months again it's exactly that it's
because when something is written from a
place of
unconscious when a when something is
written from the
unconscious uh sometimes it's not
helpful to kind of discuss it it with
you know regular uh uh language and so
as you're physically experiencing the
thing suddenly that makes sense there
were things in this movie that like
suddenly the character is walking
outside of his car and he's going to
bash somebody's head in and you're like
wait why did he come out of the car and
why is he targeting that particular
person or why is he in the bathroom
getting into a fight with this
particular innocent person and when
you're acting in it you're like oh right
of course because he just experienced
like this severe repression of his own
rage and scene X and so of course scene
Y is going to have that manifest in some
bastardized way of like you know feeling
ashamed from you know his girlfriend
who's pregnant and feeling worried about
having a baby and like attacking
somebody in the mall bathroom of course
it makes sense because that shame leads
to an expression of violence that can
only that can be the only solution to
that shame I was very interested in kind
of the I'll say shades of masculinity
that you've taken on I think of Mark in
The Social Network I think of vivarium I
think of this what is it that draw you
to these types of characters who are
struggling with identity and themselves
and it manifests in often very hurtful
or violent ways to others around them um
yeah I mean I I grew up like you know as
like a I was a small kid in a you know
in an environment where like kind of
jocks were celebrated I mean probably
like most people on Earth I'm speaking
for but I didn't grow up in like an
artsy kind of school and so the people
that were celebrated were all the people
that made me feel like you know just
inadequate and so I could understand
exactly these feelings of struggling
with your own masculinity against
expectations you have for yourself that
Society has expectations and so to me
these kind of roles feel incredibly
uh natural and
intuitive you know I I do these other
movies now you see me we're about to do
like a third one these are like you know
commercial movies and plot kind of
driven movies but the character I play
which I got to help create because the
script was kind of in its nent stage
when they first came to me for it like I
wanted to play like this kind of very
confident showman because not what I
normally feel in life and so when I'm
playing those roles a they're just a
blast to do but B those are kind of more
of a struggle for me to kind of figure
out wait why would this person have so
much confidence why would this person
think that they're so great because
that's not like usually the mindset of
an actor usually the mindset of an actor
is usually coming from a place of pain
and adequacy and they need the roles to
make them feel whole and so those are
more of the struggle for me and more or
like and really less intuitive as
opposed to the movies you just mentioned
which feel quite personal and seamless
oh that's very interesting because I did
want to ask about now you see me briefly
I won't have you do a magic trick or
anything but when you're does does doing
that type of part of it help you get
into the confidence of it and and what
kind of was this new movie like as an
evolution from all the work that you
were talking
about yeah uh well thank you so much for
saying that and yeah when I I discovered
that I don't like um actively pursue
what you would call like method acting
which is where you kind of like almost
treat the circumstances as reality and I
found that not a lot of actors do or
some do it kind of performatively but in
a way that doesn't feel exactly real and
for me doing those movies now you see me
more than
anything is our are like the furthest I
go in terms of like I would say feeling
like the character because I am an
actual performer as my job and the
character is a performer and yet the
character is this very confident
performer and I'm a very unconfident
performer experiencing self-doubt I
don't watch any of the movies I've been
in I try to avoid still frames of the
movies because I don't want to see
myself because I'm just you know
encumbered with my own anxieties about
myself and so getting to be a performer
that feels good about himself and
actually be on a movie set where I am
performing is like I would say the most
con most method I felt I walk around
almost arrogant on these sets i l why I
love them so much and I'm so desperate
for to do a one because it's like the
only times I could kind of lower my
anti-depressant dosage because I feel so
at ease and comfortable with myself as a
performer because the character is and
so in some ways like you know the way I
would describe like method acting would
almost be in the reverse that the
character is making you feel certain
something about yourself and that's what
it is for me in those movies whereas a
movie like manad Drome which appears to
audiences probably like a far more
difficult kind of role because the movie
is so intense to me feels much more like
in my comfort zone or or not Comfort
because it's not comfortable but in like
a place I'm familiar with